you have characterized uh the tunin
horse as an anti- Genesis a myth of
anti- Creation in which everything that
man once received from God is now taken
back finally the light and therefore the
good because God is dead anyway but how
how should you view this anti creation
myth related to the world of today is it
a warning or do you think that the Doom
you outlined in your movie is
inescapable and that we're already
living towards
it you know
uh yes uh the God created the
world during of Sixth Day first day he
divided the dark the
light
but we just decided we turn it back
everything because this movie is talking
about the
horse and
the death of the
horse and and the death
generally which is you know it's really
horrible thing we all will
die and it's no no chance mhm nobody can
survive anyway it doesn't mean I'm
pessimistic because I I really I really
like to leave and I really like uh the
people and I
just how you wrot
it in this booklet quoting F who
who said he just start
to learn the
looking that's what filmmaker is doing
mhm watching the life doing the
life moved by something touched by
something and then transforming on
yourself and then sharing with the
people and then if you look at the world
as you did when you made this movie this
is what you see the light will go
out you can see I'm sure everybody has
somebody who passed away mhm and it's
you are
facing with the fact mhm and
it's I cannot say it's bad or good good
or no it's a fact yes so I am very close
to what was said before that the
question is not to be optimistic or
pessimistic mhm uh so we saw just now uh
images of U so to speak I don't want to
summarize but uh the extinction of
design
mhm they are not hungry the the horse
does not eat M the woman does not eat
they are not hungry they are not
angry also extension of
the however in spite of all
however uh these images are not
pessimistic at all at all no um in the
few late months of his life Benyamin
valter Benyamin wrote we must organize
our
pessimism which is beautiful mhm of
course he committed suicide some months
later but we have the
text it is
transmitted so it is a
considerable um amount amount of Hope
and this amount of Hope is goes in
Benjamin's idea himself from G MH to
Kafka who
said we have a lot of Hope but not for
not for
us this is BR this indicates the
importance of what uh was called this
this morning tradition transmission Etc
MH so I just wanted to add to this um
list I mean you know gr she talked of
the pessimism of the intellect and the
optimism of the will and I think in
these beautiful and extremely moving
images of bare Humanity that Bella has
given us there is in their very Beauty a
kind of optimism and the optimism of
having made that into art we are left
we've got bare Humanity we've got an
absolutely brutal non- Desiring
situation and yet and yet there is
Beauty in
it